CONTINUE.
BRET.
>> Bret: MIKE, THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, THE SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> GLAD TO BE WITH YOU, BRET.
>> Bret: THE NEGOTIATIONS OVER
A CORONAVIRUS BILL, POSSIBLE?
>> I HOPE SO.
I’VE BEEN TRYING TO GET AN
OUTCOME HERE FOR QUITE A WHILE
AS YOU MAY RECALL A FEW WEEKS
AGO I PUT A RESCUE PASSAGE SO MY
PACKAGE ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE TARGETING JOBS,
HEALTH CARE AND LIABILITY
PROTECTION AND AT THAT POINT, WE
COULDN’T GET A SINGLE DEMOCRAT
TO VOTE FOR SO I THINK WHAT’S
HAPPENED HERE IS WE’VE GOTTEN
CLOSER TO THE ELECTION.
THE SPIRIT OF BIPARTISANSHIP.
>> Bret: WHAT IS YOUR NUMBER?
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING
THEY’VE COME DOWN.
WHAT IS YOUR NUMBER?
WHAT CAN YOU STOMACH?
>> WHAT I PUT ON THE SENATE
FLOOR THREE WEEKS AGO WAS ABOUT
A HALF A TRILLION DOLLARS,
NARROWLY TARGETED AT EXACTLY
WHAT THE ECONOMY NEEDS AT THIS
POINT.
WHAT THE SPEAKER DID, EVEN AFTER
COMING DOWN IN FULL TRILLION
DOLLARS IS THROW EVERYTHING YOU
CAN IMAGINE INTO THE PACKAGE,
INCLUDING TAX CUTS FOR RICH
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND
NEW YORK AND FREE HEALTH CARE
FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THAT SORT OF THING IS NOT
APPROPRIATE.
>> Bret: SO YOU SOUND PRETTY
PESSIMISTIC.
>> LOOK, I’D LIKE TO GET ANOTHER
RESCUE PACKAGE.
I THINK THERE’S MORE THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE FOR THE ECONOMY, BUT
IT’S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER WE
ALREADY NOW HAVE DEBT THE SIZE
OF OUR ECONOMY FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE WORLD WAR II.
THIS HAS GOT TO STOP UNLESS IT’S
NARROWLY TARGETED AT THE PROBLEM
PROBLEM.
>> Bret: BUT ONE MORE TRY, IF
THEY COME DOWN TO 1.2, CAN YOU
GET THERE TO >> I’M NOT GOING TO
NEGOTIATE WITH YOU.
THE PRINCIPAL NEGOTIATIONS
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, IF THEY
CAN REACH AN AGREEMENT I’LL TAKE
A LOOK AT IT AND SEE WHETHER I
CAN SELL THAT TO SENATE
REPUBLICANS.
>> Bret: SPEAKING OF SELLING
IT, HAVE YOU DEFINITIVELY
DECIDED THAT IF AMY CONEY
BARRETT GETS OUT OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, LET’S SAY
OCTOBER 22ND, AS PLANNED, THAT
YOU WILL HAVE A VOTE BEFORE
ELECTION DAY?
>> I HAVEN’T DECIDED WHEN THE
VOTE WOULD OCCUR ON THE FLOOR,
BUT WE DO ANTICIPATE
JUDGE BARRETT COMING OUT OF
COMMITTEE ON OCTOBER 22ND.
I THINK THAT’S A PRETTY LIKELY
OUTCOME AND IT WILL DECIDE WHEN
WE GO FORWARD.
>> Bret: HOW MUCH DEBATE TIME
SHOULD THERE BE FOR A LIFETIME
APPOINTMENT?
>> WELL, THERE’S PLENTY OF
DEBATE GOING ON IN COMMITTEE, IT
STARTED TODAY, EVEN WITHOUT THE
NOMINEE THERE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE I THINK
REALLY NEED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET TO MEET AND KNOW JUDGE
JUDGE BARRETT THAT WILL HAPPEN
DURING THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
HEARINGS.
WE WERE CALLING EACH OTHER
HYPOCRITES BEFORE.
WHAT WE NEED TO SEE IS NOMINEE.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT OVER
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS, SPECTACULAR
AND INCREDIBLE LIFE STORY,
WONDERFUL FAMILY, FIVE KIDS, TWO
ADOPTED KIDS, ONE SPECIAL NEEDS
KID AND ONE OF HER PROFESSORS AT
NOTRE DAME WROTE AN OP-ED IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" RECENTLY
SAYING SHE WAS THE SINGLE MOST
BRILLIANT STUDENT HE’D EVER HAD
IN ALL OF HIS YEARS TEACHING LAW
AT NOTRE DAME.
>> Bret: FOR THE ELECTION
LOOKERS WHO SAY HOW DOES THE
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE, AMY CONEY
BARRETT, PLAY FOR THESE TYPE
REPUBLICAN RACES, HOW DO YOU SEE
IT AS FAR AS IF YOU GET THIS
NOMINEE THROUGH, HOW DOES IT
PLAY IN THOSE RISKS?
>> WELL, THE PENDING NOMINATION
I THINK IS A BIG ASSET.
I’M HAPPY TO PUT THIS NOMINEE
FRONT AND CENTER IN MY CAMPAIGN.
I’M HAPPY TO TELL THE VOTERS OF
KENTUCKY MY OPPONENT WOULD
OPPOSE THIS OUTSTANDING NOMINEE.
I THINK IT’S AN ASSET IN MY
STATE AND AN ASSET AND MANY,
MANY STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
>> Bret: LET’S SAY YOU DON’T
GET IT BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
LAST QUESTION ON THIS.
AN ELECTION HAPPENS, LET’S SAY
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE,
OPTIMISTICALLY YOU HOLD ONTO THE
SENATE MAJORITY, BUT THERE WILL
BE SOME SENATORS IN YOUR CAUCUS
WILL LOSE.
IS IT OKAY FOR A LAME DUCK
SENATE TO VOTE ON A
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE TO BE A
JUSTICE?
>> WELL, THIS REPUBLICAN SENATE
WAS ELECTED FOR A TERM THAT ENDS
IN JANUARY OF NEXT YEAR.
THE PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED FOR A
FOUR-YEAR TERM THAT ENDS JANUARY
THERE ARE NO REDUCED
CONSTITUTIONAL PREROGATIVES THAT
DURING EITHER OF OUR TENURES AND
IN FACT, YOU’LL REMEMBER, TWO
YEARS AGO WHEN MY PARTY ACTUALLY
GAINED TWO SEATS IN THE SENATE
WHILE WE WERE LOSING THE HOUSE,
THE BIGGEST ISSUE IN THE
CAMPAIGN WAS A SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE, BRETT KAVANAUGH.
>> Bret: HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE
THE DEBATE THAT HAPPENED THE
OTHER NIGHT?
>> WELL, IT WASN’T
LINCOLN-DOUGLAS, I CAN TELL YOU
THAT.
>> Bret: DOES IT HURT YOUR
SENATE FOLKS WHO ARE UP FOR
ELECTION THIS TIME?
>> THERE WILL BE TWO MORE
DEBATES AND I HOPE BOTH THE
CANDIDATES WILL APPROACH THE
NEXT DEBATE IN A LITTLE MORE
RESPECTABLE WAY.
IT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA I THINK
TO LET EACH OF THE CANDIDATES
FINISH THEIR ANSWERS, BUT LOOK,
THEY ARE THE CANDIDATES, THEY
GET TO DECIDE HOW TO ENGAGE WITH
EACH OTHER AND WE’VE GOT TWO
MORE TO GO AND I’M HOPING THERE
WILL BE A LITTLE BETTER FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE VIEWING.
>> Bret: HERE’S HOW THE HILL
WROTE IT.
THEY SAID INSTEAD OF SPENDING
ONE STATE TOUTING NOMINEE AMY
CONEY BARRETT, SENATE
REPUBLICANS FIELDED QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT’S REFUSAL TO
REBUKE WHITE SUPREMACIST GROUPS
OR COMMIT TO A PEACEFUL TRANSFER
OF POWER.
SENATOR TILLIS, TRAILING HIS
OPPONENT IN RECENT POLLS,
DECLARED WHAT’S A PREMISE HE AND
ANY ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
ANTAGONISTIC SHOULD BE CONDEMNED
24/7.
SENATOR DAINES, WHO IS IN A
TOUGH REELECTION RACE EQUIPPED
IT WAS A BARROOM BRAWL AND AS WE
SAY IN MONTANA, IT GOT A LITTLE
WESTERN AT TIMES.
SO IT JUST TAKES SOME DAYS AWAY
FROM THE CAMPAIGNS.
>> WITH REGARD TO WHAT’S A
PHARMACY, THERE’S NO PLACE FOR
THAT IN AMERICA.
I AND OTHERS, ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES CONDEMN IT IN THE
STRONGEST POSSIBLE TERMS, THANKS
TO SENATOR TIM SCOTT -- I THINK
HE SAID IT PROBABLY BETTER THAN
ANYONE.
WE ALL WOULD BE BETTER OFF
IMMEDIATELY CONDEMNING WHITES OF
PHARMACY WHEREVER WE HEAR
REFERENCES TO IT.
>> Bret: IF THE ELECTION DOES
NOT GET DECIDED ON NOVEMBER 3RD
AND THERE ARE SOME STATES THAT
ARE STILL HAVING PROBLEMS
GETTING TO FINDING THEIR FINAL
NUMBER OR THEIR ELECTORS, HOW DO
YOU THINK THAT WOULD LOOK FROM A
CONGRESSIONAL PERSPECTIVE?
>> WELL, IT COULD HAPPEN.
I MEAN, THERE’S NO QUESTION THAT
HOW ELECTIONS ARE CONDUCTED OR
DECIDED IN EACH OF OUR STATES
AND SOME STATES HAVE ADOPTED AN
APPROACH TO THIS WITH REGARD TO
THE COUNTING OF MAIL-IN BALLOTS
THAT COULD DELAY THE RESULTS.
IT COULD HAPPEN.
WE WILL HAVE TO WAIT TO FIND OUT
WHO WON.
BUT, THERE’S NOTHING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN DO ABOUT THAT.
[INDISCERNIBLE] TO CONDUCT AN
ELECTION A CERTAIN WAY, THAT’S
THE WAY IT WILL BE CONDUCTED.
IN MY STATE FOR EXAMPLE WE USED
A MOSTLY VOTE IN PERSON.
THIS TIME THERE WILL BE MORE
MAIL-IN VOTING BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
I ACCEPT THAT AS THE OUTCOME IN
MY STATE OF HOW THE ELECTION IS
GOING TO BE CONDUCTED AND I WILL
ADJUST MY CAMPAIGN ACCORDINGLY.
WHO KNOWS?
I MEAN, WE THINK THIS WILL BE
SETTLED WELL BEFORE THE END OF
THE YEAR NO MATTER, YOU KNOW,
HOW MANY STATES MAY END UP
HAVING SHORT-TERM ELECTION
DISPUTES.
WE SOUGHT IN 2000 GO ON FOR FIVE
WEEKS, BUT [INDISCERNIBLE] IN
TIME FOR THE NEW PRESIDENT AND A